the communication
on the green deal industrial plan
this communication comes
with the backdrop of the knowledge that
we are living now in a decisive time
basically the decade that will decide on
whether we're going to be successful in
fighting climate change or not and we
know that in the fight against climate
change most important is the Net Zero
industry
we want to seize this moment
we know that in the next years the
shape of the economy The Net Zero
economy and where it is located will be
decided
and we want to be an important part of
this Net Zero industry that we need
globally
we have a very strong starting point as
a European of Net Zero Technologies
we've started three years ago we were
the first with the European green deal
we have cast our goals in a law we were
also the first to do that
we have a detailed road map that is fit
for 55.
and from the very beginning on three
years ago we were very clear that we are
convinced that the European green deal
is our new growth strategy
I was I think 90 days in office then the
pandemic hit
this did not stop us
it's basically the contrary
we seized the crisis to move forward
you remember that we introduced Next
Generation EU
and in Next Generation EU the resilience
and Recovery Fund which is 725 billion
euros dedicated
uh 37 of this RF to the green transition
actually member states even overshoot
they are at 40 percent now
so this next Generation you due to the
pandemic but with a clear focus on the
green transition was the first
accelerator if I may call it so in our
European green deal
the second accelerator that we had was
the Russian war of aggression and it's
triggering of the energy crisis
you recall almost a year ago we were
heavily dependent on Russian fossil
fuels Russia blackmailed us with
threatening to cut the energy Supply
actually they have cut 80 percent of
pipeline gas in eight months only we did
not give in
we resist it we decided to speed up the
transition or the diversification away
from Russian fossil fuels to other
suppliers and most importantly to
accelerate the investment and Renewables
for that we tabled repower EU in May
last year
repower EU is focused on reducing Demand
on increasing efficiency and as I said
in accelerating the deployment and
infrastructure of Renewables
actually last year we doubled the
additional deployment of renewable
energy
and for the very first time we generated
more electricity from Renewables than
for gas from gas
but this is only the beginning because
now we see the third accelerator in this
story
we see that major economies rightly so
are stepping up the investment in the
net zero industry
if you look at Japan and the green
transformation plants they have now put
forward 140 billion euros through green
transition bonds if you look at India
they've put forward the so-called
production-linked incentive scheme
massive investment in photovoltaic
massive investment in batteries
UK Canada many others have also put
forward their investment plans and the
new the United States have passed the
inflation reduction Act
let me be very clear on this one
we welcome this this is good news we
have since long argued that the fight
against climate change is a must
a must for our planet
a must for our economic prosperity
and a must for our strategic
Independence we are competitive
we need competition
what we are looking at is that we have a
Level Playing Field in the global
competition as well as a Level Playing
Field within the single Market this is
for us so important
therefore what are our next steps the
communication that we present today has
four pillars
first of all a conducive regulatory
environment for the Net Zero Industries
Second National and EU funding
third the ensuring of proper skills for
the green transition
and an ambitious trade agenda is the
force pillar
let me have a look at the first pillar
we all know that to grow
our Net Zero Industries need the right
framework
it has to be simpler it has to be faster
and it has to be more predictable
we will therefore propose The Net Zero
industry Act
it will focus on the key Technologies
for the shift to Net Zero
it will speed up permitting this is one
of the major complaint when you speak to
the business The Net Zero industry the
major complaint is always the permitting
processes
and it will incentivize multi-country
projects
a big focus is on cutting red tape
and it will set targets for what we need
till 2030 because there's a simple
equation only what gets measured gets
done
we need to we know that we need to
secure the volumes needed for raw
materials for that we will propose a
critical raw materials Act
its aim is to facilitate the extracting
the processing but also the recycling in
the European Union and of course the
search for substitutes
then energy
as explained is in particular
alongside the raw materials energy and
electricity the other core element
our industry requires to be competitive
on
so we will come forward also in March
with the electricity Market design
because electricity users should be able
to to benefit from the low costs of
Renewables
this is the first pillar the regulatory
environment
the next the second pillar is the
funding
and here we have at National level one
instrument that is well known that is
State eight to promote investment in
strategic sectors
we all know that the European Union has
already a temporary crisis framework in
place since the beginning of Russia's
war in Ukraine
we will further adapt it now to the Net
Zero industry requirements and important
is it has to be targeted
these adaptation and it has to be time
Limited
will after this press conference present
the changes of the adaptation for public
consultation that starts today in state
8.
very important if we look at State 8 we
must be careful and avoid any kind of
fragmentation of the single market so
the Level Playing Field or the single
Market internally is as important as the
level field that playing field we want
globally
and therefore for me always if you have
state aid the other side of the coin has
to be funding at the EU level
we need this
first step of funding now
so we cannot wait too long we need a
bridging solution
to later other financing instruments but
at the moment being we need to work with
what we have right now and focus it on
the cleantech industry
this means we want to leverage the
possibilities provided by repower EU
by invest EU and by The Innovation fund
you recall that I said repower EU has
been proposed by us
in May last year it took quite a while
till it was agreed now it's up and
running it's ready to go
and we are we initially proposed it to
get rid of the dependency of Russian
fossil fuels and initially we were
discussing whether we are able to do
that till 2027
or earlier well you know now that we
have gotten rid of our dependency
completely of Russian fossil fuels it
went much faster than we expected that's
good so
so we have the possibility
to redirect or reorient
the additional funding of re-power EU
it's about 250 billion euros
to our Net Zero Industries
for this we will enable and encourage
the member states to use the money from
repower EU for example with for tax
breaks
to The Net Zero industry because this
mirrors then the speed the
predictability and the target targeted
Way Forward as we see for example from
competitors it's fast it's predictable
it is targeted
the second
um element in this ready to go or
available funds is invest EU we will
assess how funding could be increased
invest EU has a different approach
repower EU goes to member states with
view on the net zero industry invest EU
looks at projects
it catalyzes private investment through
guarantees to the eib and the national
promotional Banks
in other words it eases the access to
funding at crucial moments of new
product developments for Innovative
projects for pioneering companies for
state-of-the-art Industries so this is
more looking at the company or the
project level
and the third element also looking at
projects is the Innovation fund which we
will work with production which will
work with production subsidies for key
Technologies
as I said this this bridging we need
right now
for a midterm solution
in the context of the review of the
multi the mff
when we will propose to set up a
European sovereignty fund
this European Serenity fund is targeted
at boosting resources available for
Upstream research for Innovation and for
strategic industrial projects
and this is the main element that we're
looking at but it takes more time to
develop it
that was the funding the second pillar
the third pillar is skills
you can we will only be successful in
having a prosperous Net Zero industry
here in the European Union if there are
enough skilled Personnel is enough
skilled personnel and you know that
already today companies are desperately
looking for personnel I'm not only
speaking about skilled Personnel but
also just Personnel nearly 30 percent of
businesses in the manufacturing
electrical equipment for example say
that they should face labor shortages
right now already
so the green deal industrial plan will
focus on this topic
we have our packed for skills we have
the European year Force skills just a
few figures that show where we really
have to get better
we have an impressively low unemployment
employment rate that's good six percent
roundabout
average in Europe
so the distribution is also different in
the different member states but six
percent on average
but if we look at specific groups we see
that youth unemployment is at 14 what a
waste of talent and opportunities so we
have to get better there
if you look at female participation in
the labor market it's 69 male
participation in the labor market is 80
percent
so there we can get better also with
women accessing the labor market this
has to do with infrastructure and family
policies good schools good child care
but we can do something about it and if
you look at the older workers the older
employees my age group 60 to 64. only 48
percent
participating in the Labor Workforce
here to what an amount of wisdom that we
are not using and experience in our
labor market and the fourth pillar is
migration we have around about three
million people legally migrating to the
European Union joining the labor market
important topic
Force pillar is straight
we will work on our positive trade
agenda we are working to conclude
agreements at the moment being with
Mexico chile New Zealand and Australia
we are making progress with India and
Indonesia and we need to restart a
conversation regarding the Mercury
agreement because we know we need
International Trade It establishes
Supply chains creates jobs and develops
helps our industry to develop new
products so this was a long introduction
I stopped here or perhaps one more
sentence the way to go forward this is
the communication that we put forward
then of course we will have the
political debate in the European Council
on the nines of February
and in view of the input that we get we
will then shape the legal proposals by
mid-march early enough to discuss that
then in the European Council the regular
European Council on the 23rd of March
thank you very much before we move to
your questions let me just remind you
that we will also have a technical
briefing later on this afternoon at
around 3 P.M
good afternoon I'm president Jorge
Valero with Bloomberg a question on the
serenity fund um because I think
according to your estimates the um the
money the EU funds dedicated or
committed to clean investment by 2030
it's around 30 380 billions already
and
um this is more or less aligned with uh
what the the Biden Biden Administration
has proported for the for his cleantec
art and at the same time China
China's investment include Tech so far
is it's been committed to around 280
billion euros I think it's that's what
the Georgia argument says so my question
is how much money do you think that this
sovereignty fund should have and whether
it should be Finance via joint borrowing
or for example the eib or other
instruments will play uh the big the big
the main role
I can underline it because you all this
what you cited from the communication
against that backdrop
um the sovereignty fund
has the idea that we need for common
European projects that are key
technology cutting-edge key technology
common European funding also to be sure
that these key Technologies are
spread all across the European Union and
have access to the necessary funding so
it looks a bit broader than the focus we
have today on the bridging solution and
the definition I just gave it's
basically to have a European Edge on the
critical and emerging Technologies so
include mentally topics like
microelectronics or the quantum
Computing or the artificial artificial
intelligence but also biotechnology and
of course the Net Zero technology we
need for these common European project
that of crucial importance to be a
relevant Global player a common European
funding and therefore it fits well that
we have the review of the mff but of
course we have to speak with the member
states about other financing techniques
for me it's important that we Define now
also with our needs assessment what
exactly is it what we are looking at so
what are the needs and what are the
topics in the sovereignty fund the
principle I think is clear
and that we then go to uh the financing
techniques
dude
thank you very much David Carreta
radiological Italian radio to question
if I if I may uh several several member
states that said that the this approach
on state AIDS could could lead to a
subsidy race inside the European Union
I'm wondering what would be your your
answer on on that specific point the
second point is on solidarity the
president of the European Council said
publicly that there is a need of
solidarity
to guarantee the Level Playing Field in
the internal market and imagine it
that instrument common that instrument
like sure has a possible solution
that was an idea also of two of your
commissioner gentilonian and Brito I'm
wondering why you have decided to avoid
the issue of solidarity in this
communication
and if you would be ready to to put
forward the proposal uh on adapt
instrument if tasked by the European
Council thank you
so um if I start with the letter
um
the
an amazing impressive expression not
only of solidarity but also of trust to
the European level
wasn't is next Generation EU
it was the very first time
that member State trusted and trusted
the European level to go to the Capital
Market raise the money with the
guarantees of the member states you know
the mechanism it has never happened
before
in the other crisis it was always
intergovernmental solution that were
looked at so next Generation you is an
outstanding element of solidarity I'm
glad that we have it and re-power EU
is a window of Next Generation you
repower you takes the left over not used
loans quite a substantial amount 225
billion
and makes it possible enables the member
states to flexibilize these loans and to
use them targetly for the Net Zero
industry
um the same goes of course for many
other topics that are in The Proposal
how to fund the necessary investment now
for the Net Zero industry now what sure
is concerned indeed I've been a strong
supporter offshore in the pandemic
because it was a massive threat
to the companies and the lockdowns
brought along that companies uh because
not having any orders anymore the
breakdown of the supply chain had to lay
off their personnel
so it's an excellent instrument that I
introduced at that time
for the short time support of Labor to
keep people in the companies not to lay
them off
at the moment being we have a different
situation we have not the threat that
people are being laid off but we have
the problem that skilled Personnel is
necessary so companies are desperately
looking
for people joining the company
skilled Personnel coming to the company
and therefore I think that's important
that we look at the needs at the moment
being to focus our programs on that one
what uh your second question or first
question was on state aid
indeed my data will be
more detailed on that but I think
important is that the state aid which is
the national money that you can then
invest is targeted and that it is
temporary
and if we look at what is it targeted
then it's very clearly defined on six
cleantech areas
this is batteries it's solar panels it's
wind turbines heat pumps electrolyzers
and CC us so carbon capture usage and
storage very clearly defined and these
are the critical
key industry at the moment being where
we have to
give an alternative
to the offers they get from abroad we
want this industry to stay here and to
prosper here we've listened very
carefully to the industry also
what their
view on this is
and in general as I said we are
competitive
we have a relatively high energy
environment compared for example to the
United States so it doesn't make it
easier but if on top then
tax breaks come into play it's important
that we are able also to say we have the
matching possibility here either through
State 8 or and this is very important
those members State who cannot take the
state aid can apply the same rules lies
in state 8 and tax break like investor
repower EU money
thank you very much I had Angela Mauro
on the chat an entire show please switch
on your camera
and your microphone Angela yes
yes I mean you can see me uh
you know the Sovereign sovereignty fund
even though I know that you don't have a
timeline you're saying that it takes
time but you're saying also that for the
next Generation you in in a few weeks
Europe was capable of elaborating this
this miracle
in your wish I mean as the the era the
United States plan is already will be
active in in March so as we need this
fund I mean as soon as we can what you
can as timeline what would you imagine
at the end of the year uh by the summer
uh I know it's very difficult but if you
can give us
an idea of when could be the time to to
to to have this fund thanks yes um I'm
sorry if I was not clear enough or
perhaps one point for Next Generation EU
at the beginning
um it's very important to keep in mind
Next Generation EU I started to discuss
the option that was shortly before
Easter
um in that year I think it was yeah it
was 2020 that when the pandemic hit
and
um it took us
basically the whole rest of the year to
get it up and running we had this famous
Council in July if I recall it correctly
where we spend three or four days trying
to get Next Generation you and other
topics up and running
until it was approved to all the member
states it was December
so it and then we started with the plans
so it took us quite a while although it
was for European purposes uh an amazing
step forward
that's next Generation EU and describing
that
um I want and I perhaps I was not clear
enough we need indeed now the investment
but we also need a structural answer for
the mid and long term and the investment
that is now available is the opportunity
to reorient what we've done now today
the repower EU by giving guidance new
guidance to Next Generation EU that you
can use this money in the member states
now for example with tax breaks for the
critical companies that you want to keep
in your country so we have this money
and it is around about 250 billion as I
said immediately available on top comes
possibility of invest EU and Innovation
fund this gives us a bridge
till we have a structural answer to how
are we dealing with key technologies
that of common European interests and
where we need a common European funding
and this discussion will go along with
the summer and I cannot give you a
precise timeline now
hi uh littlewood for context so I had
two questions the first one is something
that you mentioned in Davos you said
that the Net Zero industry act would
follow the the path of the chips act
that was proposed earlier last year
um I'm wondering if your intention or
the intention of the commission is to
use the same toolbox that were used for
the chips act for a limited number of
key industrial sectors or if the
intention of the commission was to
create a more General framework for
European industry that could be used
later on in the future whatever those
key industrial sectors might be and if
the list of those key industrial sectors
was already defined or if there was
still some studies and impact assessment
that needed to be done and my second
question is regarding the speeding up of
Permitting processes how do you intend
to conciliate the objectives of
the industrial imperative let's say
today with other green deal objectives
and I'm especially thinking of the
nature restoration objectives on
biodiversity is this not contradictory
with the permitting processes fast
tracking that you were mentioning
earlier thank you
so perhaps to take the second question
first they you always have to find the
balance that is true
but the definition of go-to areas in the
permitting process
gives the opportunity to drastically
reduce the permitting time you know that
permitting time partially is six to nine
years
of
deployment of for deployment of
renewable energy
and if we look at the balance that you
have to find in these go-to areas we
will have if we're not faster with a
deployment of renewable energies we will
not be successful in fighting climate
change and climate change is the biggest
threat the biggest threat to any kind of
biodiversity the biggest threat to any
kind of nature of course also the
biggest threat for the human beings so
um if you have to look at what is the
most effective way to fight climate
change then the deployment of renewable
energy so getting writ of the CO2
emissions and the fossil fuel based
industry
processes then of course the choice is
clear that you put a lot of emphasis on
um on the deployment of renewable energy
within the permitting uh go to areas
there are definitions so it's not you
can do whatever you want there's a clear
framework but I just wanted to explain
the logic behind it
um then you were asking on yes the
definition of the Net Zero industry of
course this will be clearly defined in
the net zero industry act that we will
put for in in
mid-march so it's pretty close and it
will be and is accompanied by needs
assessment I think this is very
important to keep that in mind that we
have a very clear idea what are the
effects on what kind of sectors and
where how do we have to be present with
investment not to lose these key sectors
of the Net Zero industry and where is it
not necessary the serenity fund I said
is a bit more wider in scope because
here it is about key technologies that
we need for the digital and the twin
transition
yep
yanoshan bahaman from your active thank
you very much
um I have a question also on on the
timing of the the state aid and the
European sovereignty fund because the
state aid uh flexibilization
um and simplification you do it now but
the whole solidarity aspect that was
mentioned by colleagues before you say
that's for maybe mid 2023 and it's it's
much more vague in the
um in the communication I was wondering
how do you get countries actors that are
mostly interested in the state to then
still who who now will get their ability
to have easier access to stated how do
you get them to still support also a
solidarity aspect like a European
sovereignty fund
so perhaps again what time is concerned
my inner picture
is the following
um we have now the
state aid or renewed adapted state aid
rules that will come in a short while
and we have immediately the bridging
funding and again repower used 250
billion we have around 100 billion
through cohesion policy that is adding
to that this is money available right
now and I hope it's of utmost importance
that the member states use that money
and invest it now so it goes in parallel
to that that's very important
and then the concept of the sovereignty
fund is we need a European structural
answer on how to deal with and how to
support these key Technologies and yeah
key Technologies
we should always keep in mind no country
no member state of the European Union is
an island not a single one
the Integrity of the single market and
the functioning and the prosperity of
the single Market is the reason why
Industries are in different member
states
if you take the typical member states
with more industry they are heavily
dependent on suppliers from other member
states and you know vice versa that
other member states that have suppliers
are heavily dependent that let's say the
mother company in the bigger member
states are there still there and not go
for example to the United States or
somewhere else so this principle of
integrated Supply chains is our strength
that's our wealth that's our prosperity
here and we should I think refrain from
thinking in stove pipes that
member states could be an island they
are not
and the whole economy is or the whole
Miracle of the single Market is the
possibility that we have these
integrated Supply chains and that we are
scaling up within the European Union so
um therefore for me state it now time
limited the bridging solution which is
quite a substantial sum please invest it
now
and then the sovereignty fund which is a
structural answer
common European funding for common uh
key Technologies European key
Technologies
thank you I now go to Javier Espinosa
on the interaction platform
thank you thank you for uh please please
put on your camera yeah thank you thank
you for the opportunity can you give us
a little bit more details on the Next
Generation EU funding that you're
talking about on tax breaks specifically
how much do you how much do you think
it's going to be used for tax breaks how
easy is going to be the deployment of
that which industry is just more details
on how do you see it working now
yeah
so uh I think you meant repower EU not
next Generation you if I'm not mistaken
okay
um so Our intention is we I understand
why you brought in the Next Generation
you we give guidance today
uh within the framework of
um the resilience and the Recovery Fund
that enables the window of
repower EU
to work with tax break like models like
models and what is the reason why we do
that to be very fast
to be predictable so companies can
calculate
and to be simple
there will be a technical briefing
afterwards that if it's necessary can go
in further details but the political
steps we've taken today is the guidance
in the big Mothership let's say next
Generation you and then the window
repower EU benefits from it
thank you we'll take one last question
from Jess
thank you Jessica Parker from BBC News a
slightly different topic if I may on
brexit following some UK press reports
overnight
just on the Northern Ireland protocol
can you give us any idea of how close
the UK and the EU are now to a deal and
can you be clear would you be willing to
compromise at all on the role of the
European court of justice thank you
so um as we've said several times in the
last weeks and months I have a very
trusted and excellent relationship with
the prime minister
on several occasions we have been
talking also on the issue of the
protocol
our teams are
working together to find Solutions
to have in the very end an
implementation of a common framework
the protocol as always in negotiations
you know the principle that everything
is only negotiated at the very end when
you know what the result is and you give
a final signature so I'm very sorry but
I cannot give partial elements because
you never know what whether in the very
end how the package looks like but uh as
I said uh
this these are very constructive talks
thank you very much this brings us to
the end of our press conference it will
be followed by a another press
conference with Executive Vice President
Margaret de vestaga in particular on the
competition issues of stated issues and
then the technical briefing later on
this afternoon thank you
foreign